on a entendu parler des questions qu'on
bat les questions qu il y en a partout
sauf qu'ici au moins on avoue
jean par exemple que tu partes sur un
vaisseau spatial oui dans la paume
quatre ans sinon assez long j'espère
qu'il va bien m'entourer bhatia à france
gall ou véronique sanson je prendrais
verrou écoute elle l a dit toi
ah bon wen sont d'ailleurs tu vas donc
on est d'accord pour partie à toutes les
deux oui mais sauf qu'elle a dit qu'elle
prendrait un petit bayer pour se
protéger un madoff mais voilà en soirée
pendant le voyage
elle a dit c'est pas grave on évoque
j'aurai mon petit chemin et la sicile à
vis un moment avec elle je suis sûr de
m'éclater
je connais bien françois mitterrand tes
potes avec lui de dire françois
mitterrand bonjour il demandait dit
comme ça j'aimerais bien que vous
trouviez une maîtresse
alors est-ce que tu préfèrerais je vois
qui tue qui tue contacterait simone veil
arlette laguiller jean-claude à aa
je tenais le plus con jeu télé je t'en
citer 2 je veux dire lequel est le plus
bête j'ai pas fait gaffe sont très cons
tous les deux on va dicter d'alors le
juste prix a cédé 1,7 et les magots
réfléchit bien à un essai du juste prix
me semble très très fort encore encore
plus con que prévu mais c'est bon tout
le monde juste prix bon j'espère que ça
me fait chier imagine que tu puisses
faire interdire quelqu'un de télévision
je me dise de la culture oui tu peux
faire interdire quelqu'un télévision
est-ce que tu ferais interdite sébastien
vous savez tous ces garçons mais dans
mon parcours c'est terrible c'est
évident et cela des artistes parce qu'on
est tous les deux dès 20h30 va être
obligée de se fâcher avec l'un ou avec
l'autre
ou alors d'esquiver la question
ce qui ne serait pas très honnête non
mais j'ai pas envie de viron tout seul
sans te prends ça va c'est pareil du
côté des cas alors maintenant on va
passer aux bons sentiments comme ça oui
un jour je sais pas tu vas encore plus
de disques d'habitude et puis tu dis
quand même beaucoup d'argent
je vais faire un don de deux oeuvres
est-ce que cet argent lui préfère le
donner à des petits noirs de soweto ou à
des petites palestiniens de gaza assez
des questions dont je suis content
humeur là j'ai pas droit à choisir je
crois pour les petits plats qui
d'afrique du sud les palestiniens de
palestine
pour ça rien
en afrique en afrique du sud c'est
impressionnant et je m'en fous pas
visage face à ce choix parce que oui je
me rattraperai une autre fois alors
dernière question la pire de toutes
je fait un riche 296 et 129 sa féconde
et 287 600 ne s'achète beaucoup beaucoup
de millions on va vous conduire suppose
plus aller voter c'est ce que j'apprécie
c'est je retiens rien 289 et 120 en 1280